HOME OF THE U.S. OPEN SEE IT
ON FOX SPORTS 1 OVER THE
WEEKEND.
IT IS FRIDAY.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS, "NOTABLE QUOTABLES."
>> CANADIANS WE'RE POLITE,
WE'RE REASONABLE BUT WE ALSO
WILL NOT BE PUSHED AROUND.
>> THERE IS A SPECIAL PLACE
IN HELL FOR ANY FOREIGN
LEADER THAT ENGAGES IN BAD
FAITH DIPLOMACY WITH
PRESIDENT DONALD J. TRUMP.
>> OR TRUMP.
>> I'M NOT SURE WHAT
ACTIVITY HE IS ASKING ME TO
UNDERTAKE IN EITHER.
>> HE'S HAPPY.
>> BIGGEST SHOWOFF OF THE
21st CENTURY.
GO VIRAL ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
>> WE DEVELOPED A VERY
SPECIAL BOND.
>> KIM JONG UN.
>> HE'S A BUTCHER.
>> WORKING WITH HIM.
>> HE IS A KILLER:
EXECUTING PEOPLE.
HE HAS DONE SOME REALLY BAD
THINGS.
>> YEAH.
BUT SO HAVE A LOT OF OTHER
PEOPLE.
>> NEGOTIATE WITH DONALD
TRUMP.
IT PAYS TO HAVE A NUCLEAR
BOMB IN YOUR POCKET I THINK
HE MAY BE GOING THE EXTRA
MILE.
>> YOU CAN ATTACK ME ALL YOU
WANT.
I'M USED TO IT I ENJOY IT
HOWEVER, WHEN IT COMES TO
ATTACKING STAFF, THAT'S WHEN
YOU HAVE GONE TOO FAR.
>> GET A GOOD PICTURE OF
EVERYBODY SO WE ARE NICE AND
HANDSOME, THIN.
>> I GOT A LOT OF NICE GOOD
KISSES.
>> NOT TODAY OR TOMORROW OR
AT ANY POINT EVER GOING TO
COMMENT ON RUDY GIULIANI'S
LOVE LIFE.
>> I WILL SAY MAKES ME FEEL
VERY UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> IF IT WAS VAUDVILLE IT
WOULD BE A LOT BETTER
SPEECH.